if vodka Trump comes under fire for use
of a private email address hollywood
reminds you they are here to hate
conservatives and the new york times
tries to prep you for thanksgiving
dinner with your uncle i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
oh man lots of news breaking today I
mean just because it's Thanksgiving week
doesn't mean the news stops and we have
all of it for you right you're going to
break it all down for you here today but
we begin today with you making your
business better so you may have noticed
that your business is not performing as
well as you want it to you know we here
at the daily wire we have an optimally
performing business but one of the
reasons our business performs optimally
is because we use zip recruiter zip
recruiter allows you to find the best
employees for your job zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire is the smart way
to go and find those candidates unlike
other job sites if recruiter doesn't
wait for candidates to find you instead
zip recruiter finds them for you it's
powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes identifies people
with the right skills education and
experience for your job and actively
invites them in to apply so you get
qualified candidates fast there's no
more sorting through the wrong resumes
and no more waiting for the right
candidates to apply
it's no wonder zip recruiter is rated
number one by employers in the United
States right now my listeners can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire that's zip recruiter comm
slash daily wired Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter comm slash daily Wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire make sure your business is running
at top notch at zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire ok so we begin
today with nate silver saying that the
daily wire should basically be shot on
facebook you know there's a big story
today that's it's really kind of
fascinating his story is that all of the
tech stocks have been dying so according
to the according to The Wall Street
Journal this morning stocks have have
dropped from dramatically as tech shares
have extended their declines all of the
gains of the last year have basically
gone out the window
US stocks tumbled Tuesday putting major
u.s. index indices at risk of closing
below their October lows according to
The Wall Street Journal and wiping out
yearly gains what started as a
technology company sell-off bled into
other corners of the market as investors
dumped shares of everything from
retailers to oil and gas companies in
favor of relatively safe assets like
bonds and reliable dividend payers like
utility companies the result some
traders who stepped in to scoop up
shares in late October hoping for a
quick rebound are now in danger of
losing those potential profits and more
this puts the stock market in a tenuous
position several of those people say
and Wiggs who's managing director and
equity training at Stifel Nicolaus says
the by the dippers are getting concerned
meaning that when the stock market goes
down you tend to buy more that's what I
do according to his calculations as of
this morning about 16% of S&P 500
companies are now below their October
lows those companies range from tech
science to health care companies to
energy firms now it's just let's sell
everything well there are a couple of
reasons that this is happening one is
that the Chinese tariffs are beginning
to hit US industry America's soybean
exports which largely went to China have
now dropped by nearly 100 percent thanks
to the tariff battle that President
Trump is having with the Chinese well
they think that's well-founded or not
it's not particularly great for the
United States economy it's also
happening because Democrats just took
over Congress and a lot of businesses
see regulations on the way or at least
regulatory fights the friendly business
climate that has been created by the
Trump administration and a Republican
Congress could be stymied by a bunch of
Democrats who actually want to
investigate and regulate businesses up
the wazoo
tech stocks by the way have dropped one
of the reasons tech stocks have dropped
and nobody really wants to talk about
this in the left-wing media is because a
lot of the left-wing media is focused
like laser beams on shutting down tech
companies for not doing enough to let
Hillary Clinton win the election I
really mean this there's a tweet that
when I here's an example is the tweet
that went out today from Kevin Bruce hey
Kevin Roose is the New York Times tech
writer and he hears retweeted you
tweeted today's top stories on Facebook
are from one Ben Shapiro to Ben Shapiro
three Daily Caller
for nine CAG five TMZ seven Franklin
Graham eight Fox News ten Fox News so
the idea here is too many conservative
sites are getting too much traffic it is
bad and my facebook page is driving
enormous traffic it is just terrible
that top stories in terms of traffic
from Facebook are coming from me this
prompted Nate Silver who is the the
statistical analyst to tweet kind of
feels like Facebook has even stopped
trying is what Nate Silver tweeted out
it's like Facebook has stopped trying
because the top two traffic stories came
courtesy of my Facebook page and the
question is stop trying to what shut
down and censor conservative pages
prevent conservative dissemination of
information
ever since Hillary Clinton lost the left
has been in uproar about how to shut
down Facebook about how to make it a
wholly owned and used subsidiary
controlled by the faculties of the
Democratic Party and the mainstream
media this has been their chief focus
and this has been true since Dianne
Feinstein was calling top members of
social media companies before her and
saying if you don't get control of your
companies we're going to regulate you
you think maybe this might scare
investors in techs in tech companies you
might see that there been a bunch of
issues hitting tech companies one of
them is the privacy issue obviously
people believe that their private
information is being disseminated by
these tech companies or grabbed and used
by these tech companies but that was
always true the real change is that
since election 2016 a lot of members of
the left wing have suggested that
companies like Facebook should be
controlled by people who are more into
shutting down the conservative
distribution platforms for information
in other words they will only leave
Facebook unregulated if Facebook pledges
to do their bidding Dianne Feinstein
will only leave Facebook alone and
Facebook pledges to shut down
conservative websites if they pledge to
destroy conservative traffic base now
the reality is that Facebook does not
discriminate in favor of conservatives
of course and there are those of us on
the right who have said that Facebook
should not be regulated even when they
were destroying conservative traffic in
early 2017 with an algorithm shift as we
talked about at the time but the left
cannot stand that Hillary Clinton lost
and so now they're going to try to
control every business that allows them
to control the means of information
consumption this is their new priority
that may be having an effect on the
stock market people fear Democrats in
control of the levers of government when
it comes to the economy because they
know the Democrats in control of the
levers of the economy are going to try
to control business from the top down
whether you're talking pharmaceutical
companies whether you're talking drug
companies whether you're talking the the
banking industry whether you are talking
about tech companies all of these
companies are deeply fearful of
democratic governance you know the
reason that the economy started to
recover under Barack Obama it started to
recover under Barack Obama because the
all these companies knew that there is a
Republican Congress in charge it means
something when Democrats grab control of
the of the levers of power and the fact
that they are overtly people like Nate
Silver are overtly calling basically for
censorship of conservative outlets on
Facebook is just more evidence that the
media are fully invested
in the idea that they have to twist the
media of social media they have to twist
those those distribution systems in
order so that they can control those
from above it's it's really quite
incredible now one of the reasons they
want to control those methods of
distribution from above is that they can
control the politics of the country
obviously and that means that they can
push information that is not supremely
important so speaking of information
that is not supremely supremely
important today and then will contrast
this with a piece of very important
information today the Huffington Post is
very upset because Ivanka Trump used a
personal account to send hundreds of
emails last year related to government
business according to sources who spoke
with the Washington Post well that's not
good you shouldn't be using your
personal email for government business
but this of course led people like Nate
Silver right who wants Facebook to shut
down distribution systems for
conservatives Nate Silver tweeted this
out about Ivanka Trump he says if you're
one of those news organizations that
treated Clinton's private emails like
they were a national emergency the
solution isn't to treat Ivanka's private
emails like they're also a national
emergency rather it's to acknowledge
that you kind of screwed up on Clinton
well no it's to recognize that there was
a slight difference between Clinton's
private emails from what we know and
Ivanka's private emails now is it good
that anybody in government is using a
private email address to do business no
but it is also true that Cohen Powell
did this it is true that John Kerry did
this it is true that virtually every
public official that I know of uses a
private email address to do business
from time to time the question is
whether they are deliberately hiding
that from government discovery and
whether they set up a private server
which is what Hillary Clinton didn't set
up an email address at Gmail which would
have made her email subject to discovery
she set up a private server in her house
to allow all information to pass
directly to her and then it could be
contained in that private server which
she could then bleach and then drill and
then hammer a not quite the same thing
also we don't know if a Vanka Trump was
actually looking at classified
information in these emails or whether
it was unclassified government business
Hillary Clinton we know for a fact was
passing classified information via a
private email on a private server that
was open to hacked by foreign
governments this is not the same kind of
story at all and yet the media are
treating it as though this is just the
hypocrisy of the Republicans it's just
the apocrypha of
probably again should have Anka Trump
using a private email address for a
business no of course she shouldn't but
until we know what those emails were and
whether they were classified until we
have any evidence that she set up a
private server and then poured bleach
all over she's bleached bit and then
drilled it and then hammered it unless
we know that this is not the same thing
in any way nonetheless people on the
Left are going crazy over the suggest
shows that Ivanka is super-duper-duper
corrupt and this is what they want you
to be paying attention to they want you
to be paying attention to Ivanka Trump's
emails that are not in any way if so far
as we know like Hillary Clinton's emails
we this is what they want you to pay
attention to what they don't want you to
pay attention to is a judicial ruling
that violates virtually every basic
precept of government in in the
Constitution so here is the latest
federal judicial ruling the New York
Times reports mariam Jordan reporting a
federal judge on Monday
ordered the Trump administration to
resume accepting asylum claims from
migrants no matter where or how they
entered the United States dealing at
least a temporary setback to the
president's attempt to clamp down on a
huge wave of Central Americans crossing
the border first of all I do love that
now the media are finally acknowledging
there's a huge wave of Central Americans
crossing the border five minutes ago
they were suggesting that it wasn't a
threat at all there was nobody crossing
the border illegally Judge John Tiger of
the United States District Court in San
Francisco issued a temporary restraining
order that blocks the government from
carrying out a new rule that denies
protections to people who enter the
country illegally the order which
suspends the rule until the case is
decided by the court applies nationally
first of all it should not be the case
that a district court anywhere in the
country can shut down the federal
government full-scale across the country
that's absurd
there are hundreds of u.s. district
court judges across the United States
the idea that any one of them can issue
a temporary restraining order against
the federal government applied
nationally is just insane the judge
wrote whatever the scope of the
president's authority he may not rewrite
the immigration laws to impose a
condition that Congress has expressly
forbidden there's only one problem here
where did Congress expressly forbid him
from saying that if you enter the
country illegally we are not going to
process your asylum claims the same way
that we would process your asylum claims
if you enter the country legally yeah
I'm not
we're of the law that says that I'll
talk about this more in just one second
there's a big story because again this
is the courts stepping into areas where
they have no business we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about your investment strategy so as
we've been saying the stock market is
really volatile stock market is going
down right now but now is a good time
for you to learn how to use the stock
market because you can indeed make money
in the stock market how should you do
that if you don't know that much about
investing you should check out Robin
Hood
it's an investing app that lets you buy
and sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos
all commission-free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just the wealthy
it's a non intimidating way for stock
market newcomers to invest for the first
time with true confidence they have a
simple intuitive clear design with data
presented in an easy to just way some of
my folks at the office here have been
using Robin Hood and they've shown me
how it works it really is clear it
really is intuitive and it's super
helpful if you really don't know
anything about trading in the stock
market it's a great way to learn by
doing right now other brokerages charge
up to ten bucks for trades but Robin
Hood doesn't charge Commission fees you
trade the stocks and you keep all of
your profits they have
easy-to-understand charts they've market
data you can place a trade and just for
taps on your smartphone it is super easy
they have curated collections like 100
most popular sectors like entertainment
and social media curated categories like
female CEOs if that's something you're
into and again you learn by doing Robin
Hood right now is giving my listeners a
free stock like Apple Ford or sprint to
help you build your portfolio sign up at
Shapiro Robin Hood calm
that's Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm again
Shapiro Robin Hood calm learn to trade
in the stock market by using the best
app out there that is Robin Hood the
investing app that lets you do what you
need to do in the stock market and learn
while doing it Shapiro dot Robin Hood
comms get that free stock like Apple
Ford or Sprint's again Shapiro dot Robin
Hood calm okay so this judge says that
the administration is unable under the
law to prevent illegal immigrants people
who are jumping the border from applying
for asylum so this of course undercuts
the entire legal regime in the United
States and the entire idea here is to
direct people toward legal means of
applying for asylum and one legal mean
for applying for asylum is to walk up to
the border to a Border Patrol station
and simply ask for asylum
it is not legal however to jump the
fence and then claim asylum that is not
legal in the United States the judge's
ruling went a
according to what the ACLU on an
advocacy groups including the Southern
Poverty Law Center a far left advocacy
group in the American Civil Liberties
Union swiftly sued the administration
for effectively introducing what they
deemed an asylum ban but that is not in
fact an asylum ban this is absurd the
Trump administration signaled they would
continue to defend the policy as it
moved through the courts Katie Waldman
is a spokeswoman for the Department of
Homeland Security she said our Asylum
system is broken it is being abused by
tens of thousands of meritless claims
every year and they point out the
president has brought authorities
stopped the entrance of migrants into
the country which is true if you look at
the actual black-letter law they say it
is absurd that a set of advocacy groups
can be found to have standing to sue to
stop the entire federal government from
acting so that illegal aliens can
receive a government benefit to which
they are not entitled we look forward to
continuing to defend the executive
branch's legitimate and well reasoned
exercise of its authority to address the
crisis and our southern border as Steven
Yale lower is an immigration scholar at
Cornell he says presidents indeed have
broad discretion on immigration matters
but the bottom line is that the courts
have now introduced conditions that
don't actually exist in the law the
government's lawyers say the president
has sought to halt a dangerous and
illegal practice and regain control of
the borders because Trump administration
officials defended the regulatory change
they argued the president was responding
to a surge in migrants seeking asylum
based on frivolous claims which
ultimately led their cases to be denied
by an immigration judge the migrants
then ignore orders to leave and remain
unlawfully in the country if Trump can't
actually just ignore this court ruling
and enforce the law then he is not doing
his job as president the courts
obviously are wildly overreaching their
discretion under the law it's in its
fully crated so how much of the media
are gonna cover this judge's ruling
today in any way that reflects the state
of the law the answer is not much how
much will they cover at vanka's which
are not nearly the issue that they are
making it out to be I promise you that
the coverage will be blanket the
coverage will be enormous okay in just
one second I want to get to proof that
the that the media are as biased as you
think they are it's pretty astonishing
and and this is with regard to
Thanksgiving dinner so Thanksgiving is
coming up you're gonna have some
relative you disagree with and that
relative undoubtedly will bring up
politics whenever we have Thanksgiving
at my house
a lot of my relatives happen to be on
the left I rarely bring up politics at
the table I I don't really enjoy arguing
with my relatives because they're my
relatives what's the point of it but
invariably somebody brings up politics
and then we have a discussion that in
that usually ends with us saying let's
stop it and go watch football because
that's pretty much the only way that you
can end awkward discussions well now the
New York Times has put out a piece
called how to have a conversation with
your angry uncle over Thanksgiving this
piece is astonishing why is it
astonishing it's astonishing for what it
shows about the bias of the New York
Times okay so they have it they
basically put together a couple of model
conversations in this piece at the New
York Times model conversation number one
is you arguing with your conservative
uncle model conversation number two is
you arguing with your leftist uncle okay
so what's amazing is the approach that
the New York Times gives to the leftist
uncle versus the approach that gives to
the conservative uncle so the
conservative uncle is a full-on
the can the leftist uncle is in fact a
well stated well reasoned blue state
liberal and so I'll give you an example
so I went through this last night
because I was curious to see what the
New York Times recommended in terms of
how you should argue with your uncle at
Thanksgiving it just shows you where the
New York Times stands on this sort of
stuff this piece is written by Karen
tameria's who's a former psychiatrist
and the founder of smart politics so
they have a couple of bots you can
either argue with your angry uncle but
who is conservative or you can argue
with your your liberal angry uncle bot
so here is here is what the conservative
uncle bot says so the the conservative
uncle according to the New York Times
says Trump has been great for America
just look at the economy it's booming
and then it gives you a series of
answers that you can possibly give
including Trump's been good for the rich
or because you're on the Left right this
is you being on the Left saying Trump's
been good for the rich but not for
everybody else or are you saying you
know how is the economy been for you now
here's the part where gets really funny
if you say so it recommends the
recommendation if you are a liberal
arguing with your conservative uncle it
says Trump's been good for the economy
is that you're supposed to say so how
are you doing financially now listen to
how the New York Times rigs this
conversation your conservative
uncle is supposed to answer how am i
doing not that great
Julie but things would have been worse
under Hillary okay first of all the
Trump economy has been very good across
the board we've seen average wage gains
for the first time in years under
President Trump so the New York Times is
rigging the conversation so you're
conservative uncle is a who has
been doing poorly under the Trump
economy but is gonna argue that Hillary
would have been worse it's really
amazing and then you're supposed to say
what are your biggest economic hurdles
right now and then your uncle is
supposed to say my biggest turtles well
no matter how hard I work I can't get
ahead I'm living paycheck to paycheck
look how the New York Times is rigging
your conservative uncle right you're a
conservative uncle loves Trump but is
struggling to get ahead is living
paycheck to paycheck and is struggling
in the best economy in modern history
and that's that's how they're rigging
the conversation so of course if you're
a liberal you're gonna win that
conversation of course
right it's amazing like this is this is
their model conversation and then you're
supposed to say so you feel pretty
insecure money-wise despite how hard
you're working and then you're a
conservative uncle is supposed to say
yeah I do feel insecure money-wise and I
don't know how long I can keep up so the
New York Times has rigged it so that if
you're a liberal discussing with your
conservative uncle then it's very easy
because you're conservative uncle's a
who has never made a dollar in his
life and is suffering under the Trump
economy despite the fact that the
economy is booming now flip the script
and this is how the New York Times
recommends that you argue with your
conservative uncle so your concern argue
with your liberal uncle right here's how
the New York Times recommends you argue
with your liberal uncle
so you're liberal uncle says we need
Medicare for all health care is a human
right and you are now supposed to say
okay can you tell me more about that and
then your uncle say your uncle is
supposed to say this is your liberal
uncle say more about it sure no human
being should go without health care just
because they can't afford it and then
you're supposed to say well how do you
think we should fix this issue and your
liberal uncle being a brilliant a
brilliant well reasoned professor is
supposed to say how to fix it many
people can't even afford medications or
primary care if we expand Medicare to
include everyone
those people can get the help that they
need and then you're supposed to say so
you think the government has a
responsibility to make sure every person
has basic health care is that right and
then your uncle says a right to basic
health care yes it's a right every day
people die needlessly in this country
because they can't pay for medical
treatment and then
you're supposed to say I agree that no
one should have to go without medical
care because they can't afford it so in
other words if you're a conservative
arguing with your liberal uncle on
Thanksgiving you're supposed to agree
with him okay if you are a liberal argue
with your conservative uncle you're
supposed to point out to him that he's a
poor this is how the New York
Times says that you should have argue
with your uncle on Thanksgiving no no
there's no media bias at all none none
no media bias it's just astonishing I
love it so much in the New York Times
doing yeoman's work to prove just how
ridiculous they are every single day
okay meanwhile I want to get to
Hollywood which is about to launch a
brand-new movie that we're all very
excited about but first let's talk about
your impending death so it's always
possible you're gonna be there on
Thanksgiving you're true and on a piece
of Turkey and boom gets caught in your
throat and you're sitting there and as
your life passes before your eyes you
think shouldn't I've gotten life
insurance with that in a smart move well
before Thanksgiving that would be a very
good time to get life insurance because
having life insurance is a good feeling
it means that you feel safe and secure
if you should choke to death on that
piece of Turkey your family will still
be taken care of and they won't have to
cart you off to a pauper's grave go
check out policy genius it's the easy
way to get life insurance online in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers to find the best policy
for you and when you compare quotes you
save money it's that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance they've placed over
20 billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and auto insurance and home insurance if
you care about it they can cover it so
if you've been avoiding getting life
insurance because it's difficult or
confusing give policy genius to try just
go to policy genius.com get your quotes
apply in minutes you can do the whole
thing on your phone right now
policy genius is indeed the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance no reason
for you to plotz without making sure
your family's taken care of that's
irresponsible instead go to policy
genius comm and get those quotes apply
in minutes policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance ok
meanwhile Hollywood is getting ready to
launch a brand new film it was on the
cover of The Hollywood Reporter it's an
Oscar bait film ooh who's excited first
of all when I say Oscar bait you should
immediately run for the nearest doors
because it means that it's going to suck
whenever Hollywood makes a a movie that
is so called Oscar bait it is it is
basically just going to be a left-wing
claptrap version of a mediocre store
like the shape of water which was just
awful
but there is a new there's a new movie
that is coming out according to The
Hollywood Reporter and this new movie is
called Vice ooh what's it about well
what it is about glad you asked it what
it is about is Vice President Dick
Cheney did we need another movie about
Dick Cheney did we need a movie about
Vice President Cheney of course not this
in fact is just the latest attempt to go
after the Bush administration but
there's some telling there's something
telling about this ok so again this is
not the first attempt to get the Bush
administration there is a movie called w
with Josh Brolin which failed
dramatically to box-office have like a
twenty four million dollar budget
without without publicity and
advertising without PA it lost money at
the box office there's another box
office bomb called truth with Robert
Redford about Dan Rather's attempt to
take down george w bush with a fake
letter about military service that was a
bomb there was a there was a movie
called you're welcome America which was
a Broadway play starring Will Ferrell
where will ferrell basically paid played
george w bush as stupid Jeb Bush
none of these films actually did any
business but that is not stopping Adam
McKay who's the creator of HBO's
succession and he also did the Big Short
from taking on W and Vice President
Cheney so what exactly is driving this
Bush left office ten years ago last I
checked my calendar why are we still
doing movies about george w bush when
the only movies anyone has ever made
about barack obama are about how he
kissed his then-girlfriend Michelle
Obama and it tasted like chocolate which
was an actual an actual movie on Netflix
and why why are we still doing bush well
became well because Adam McKay hates
bush right he says that he went to a
victory party for John Kerry in 2004 and
he says everyone you could imagine was
there Tom Hanks Nicole Kidman Will
Ferrell this is once again we're like oh
they're going to lose there's no way
you'd reelect these guys after the
disaster we just had
I remember Frank Rich was on the phone
and he's like it's over and within two
minutes the entire party had cleared out
this movie is going to cost 60 million
dollars it's a 60 million dollar budget
for a movie about Vice President Cheney
in which Christian Bale puts on 45
pounds and plays Cheney as a
Machiavellian devil who wants to send
American troops into harm's way to maybe
enrich Halliburton or something the cast
is huge it includes Sam Rockwell as W
and Steve Carell as Donald Rumsfeld and
Tyler
areas Colin Powell according to McKay
Cheney was far more powerful than W
because W was stupid but here is the
punchline hey here's what here's what
McKay says he says I would choose Donald
Trump over Bush and Cheney Donald Trump
has no belief system so I would take the
hyenas the random wild animals running
through the White House over Cheney any
day of the week now the reason that I
point all of this out is because it just
demonstrates that all of the lies that
the left tells about why they don't like
president Trump they are just that
they're lies they the left doesn't like
president Trump because President Trump
is not a leftist it is that simple they
hated george w bush they hate donald
trump in fact as mckay says he hates
george w bush more than he hates Trump
not because george w bush was less
classy than trump or something but
because george w bush was more
ideologically conservative than trump
the left hates conservatives the
Hollywood left despises conservatives
not because they are classless and not
because they say things on Twitter that
offend and not because of not because
they say weird things in public at press
conferences you know the left hates
Donald Trump for the same reason that
they hate george w bush he is not a left
winger and in fact many of them hate
george w bush more than they hated Trump
because they think the bush was more
right-wing which by the way in terms of
governance is not even true Trump has
governed significantly more conservative
than President Bush ever did but this
demonstrates that so much of leftist
thought is based on just scorn smearing
scathing scorn against people who are
conservative in policy it has nothing to
do with the personality of the
commander-in-chief so when you hear
people on the Left say you know Donald
Trump has really robbed the Oval Office
really robbed the Oval Office of its
dignity understand this is not why they
dislike President Trump they dislike
President Trump because President Trump
does not agree with them on politics
it's the same reason that they hate
President Bush they hated President Bush
because Bush did not agree with them on
politics now what this has led the right
to do is nominate and elevate somebody
like president Trump why because
President Trump is fighting a cultural
battle with these people Hollywood has
been staring at us for decades and
President Trump is willing to get down
in the mud with these folks and say that
and say you guys are gross nobody cares
what you have to say you're idiots and
call them names and that's very
appealing to a lot of folks on the right
because if you treat us with with scorn
and we've been waiting for somebody to
punch you guys back and that's what
President Trump is so in other words it
is the leftist hatred for President Bush
and for Mitt Romney and for John McCain
that led to president Trump because you
guys scorned all of the Conservatives
who you derided as corrupt and evil and
then we said okay you know what
obviously being classy and nice doesn't
matter you people and in fact we need
somebody here who's not gonna be classy
and nice because you don't deserve
classy and nice you're jerks you deserve
to be smacked in the head as hard as
humanly possible and you know can do it
this guy over here this guy with the
hair that guy can do it it is because of
people like Adam McKay that Donald Trump
is president right now now we can take
this too far on the right hey the can
the problem for conservatives is that
Adam McKay and his colleagues are not
the target audience it's entertaining
for us that Adam McKay and Hollywood get
slapped right that's that's great
I enjoy it too but there's a bunch of
people in the middle of the country who
don't really like Adam McKay snake on
conservatives and they don't like to
slap back from the right and what they
actually are looking for is somebody who
can punch back you know from time to
time when appropriate but somebody who
does bring class to the Oval Office if
President Trump can confine that if you
can find that happy censor then he will
win reelection if he cannot then there's
a good shot that he won't but it is
important to remember what exactly drove
the the movement behind President Trump
what drove the movement behind President
Trump was two things the intersectional
ideal pushed by the left that said
there's a new coalition of the
dispossessed that was growing
demographically and was going to put its
boot on the throat of conservatives in
the middle of the country and then
conservatives in middle of the country
said you know what no we're not doing
this and then it was cultural Hollywood
that said you guys are all rubes you
guys are all morons or you guys are all
corrupt and evil and we said you know
what you're gonna do that to us you're
gonna call us bitter clinger and cling
to God and guns and xenophobia we're
gonna nominate this guy over here who
smacks you guys as hard as possible in
the face who grabs you like a member of
the three stooges by the nose and then
pokes you in the eyes with his with his
index and middle fingers if that's the
guy well we're gonna pick and guess what
in cultural terms it's actually working
the White House Correspondents Dinner
actually had to revise its entire way of
doing business
okay the White House Correspondents
Dinner which is supposed to be nerd prom
is where all the journalists get
together with the Hollywood folks and
they go on laugh at Republicans in the
name of journalism
well now may have decided they're not
gonna host a comedian anymore who just
goes there and rips into president Trump
and Republicans instead they're going to
bring in Ron chernow who's it biographer
of various presidents and instead of
being nerd prom with comedians and
comedy central figures it's going to be
an actual historical lecture by Ron
chernow and it'll be about journalism so
president Trump somehow fits the White
House Correspondents Association dinner
why cuz he said he wasn't gonna go he
said he wasn't gonna go and so he ended
up fixing the dinner this of course made
Hollywood crazy Michelle wolf who made a
name for herself last year at the White
House Correspondents Association dinner
earned herself a Netflix series that was
cancelled in about 35 seconds because
she's garbage at her job
she actually tweeted out the White House
Correspondents Association are cowards
the media is complicit and I couldn't be
prouder
well prouder of what of basically
finishing the dinner of destroying the
dinner the media destroyed themselves
and president Trump allowed them to do
it
these cultural battles are one of the
reasons the right loves President Trump
there's great benefit to that there
really is there's also a certain amount
of risk to it that we on the right would
do well to acknowledge because again I
don't think that it's a case of we have
to pick one or the other we can fight
the culture war at the same time that we
act classy if we can do that we'll win
if we don't then we will lose now I do
want to in just one second give you the
latest story from the intersectional
circuit plus we'll talk about the
Democrats who are a little more cohesive
than you might think
we'll talk about all of that in just one
second first let's talk about your
underwear dudes the holidays are fast
approaching things are about to get
uncomfortable between the crazy travel
schedules and awkward family gatherings
now is not the time to deal with wedgies
thankfully there is Tommy John the
revolutionary clothing company that is
redefining comfort for men and women
Tommy John has the most comfortable
underwear on the planet they could be
neat nestled all in one place they're
the perfect gift especially for dudes
who constantly adjust Tommy John
underwear sports and no wedgie guarantee
would have been super helpful for me in
high school
comfortable stay put waist bands a range
of fabrics that are luxuriously soft
feather-light moisture wicking
breathable designed to move with you not
against you that means no bunching no
riding up so if you're still on the
fence wondering if Tommy John would be a
memorable gift think about the fact that
you're not gonna have to watch your
friends and family tugging it anymore
and with limited edition holiday gifts
there's something for everyone on your
list naughty or nice
go check it out Tommy John give the gift
of fantastic comfort this holiday season
with limited edition holiday gifts from
Tommy John plus you save 20% on your
first order at Tommy John comm / Ben
that is Tommy John comm / Ben for 20%
off your first order again Tommy John
comm / Ben let them know he's saying I'm
one of Tommy's your underwear right now
they are super comfortable Tommy John
comm / Ben got 20% off your first order
go check that out right now okay I want
to talk about the craziest story of the
day Plus ESPN may be getting back to
sports which I'm very excited about I
will explain in just a second first
you're gonna have to go over and
subscribe it's a Lee Weyer calm 99 in
$9.99 a month get a subscription to
daily wear plus today at 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific all of your
questions will be answered by daily
wires own Michael Knowles why he works
here why you think he has answers I
don't know but if you're one of those
people who wants your question answered
by Michael moles one of those 7 people
who are members of Noel's immediate
family then you're going to actually
need to pay us Elisha Kraus will also be
there to host the show and keep Knowles
in line which as we all know is a
difficult job do just has a weird habit
of taking off his clothes in the middle
of the office and it really is quite
terrifying in this month's episode we'll
stream live on Daily wires YouTube and
Facebook pages it'll be free for
everyone to watch only subscribers can
ask the question so if you have a
question and you want an answer then go
check it out right now $99 a year gets
you all of the aforementioned wonders
Plus this the leftist here's how to
recalled tumblr cast your eyes upon this
grand piece of vessel where it is just
spectacular and you will enjoy every
second of owning it it is it is an
amazing amazing piece of it's not quite
machinery but it's a it's Cup it's great
it's a cup now go check that out right
now also go to youtube and itunes
subscribe leave us a review on iTunes
that always helps us with our ranking we
always appreciate we have the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
okay so before we get to the craziest
story of the day and we're talking here
about the the fact that Republicans can
be sucked in I think by Hollywood's
hatred for Republicans into fighting
this culture war and the culture war is
really important I wrote an entire book
Co primetime propaganda about how folks
on the Left use the cultural means of
distribution in order to try and harm
conservatives how they see conservatives
as less lesser human beings and this
latest example this movie that they're
spending 60 million dollars on just to
make fun of Dick Cheney like this is a
perfect example of that and this is why
people on the right really love
President Trump because he doesn't take
crap from people because when people
malign him when people maligned
conservatives he is willing to stand up
and say no and that's great you know it
really is good but it is also important
to recognize that you have to appeal to
the middle of the country and you can't
just rely on Democrats making mistakes
right now there's a narrative that's
going around on the right that the
Democrats are sort of falling apart and
this is being pushed by some folks on
the Left who wants to see a an inter
nation warfare among Democrats so for
example they're pushing this idea that
16 Democrats have released a letter
pledging not to support House Minority
Leader Nancy Pelosi to be Speaker of the
House the letter indicates Pelosi has
been of a math problem but she's gonna
be able to overcome the opposition for
signature for starters that were
supposed to be 17 signatures
representative Marcia fudge of Ohio
who's deeply radical was toying with the
speaker on herself but she was removed
from the letter and this is the
important point is that folks on the
right are waiting for a Bernie Sanders
versus Hillary Clinton brawl
free-for-all in the Congress they are
thinking that Democrats are going to
schism the way that they did in 2016 I
have my doubts that that's actually
going to happen I think that that's
that's probably an overreach of the
situation I think that the Democratic
Party and Pelosi particularly are clever
enough that they can act as though there
is a schism without there actually being
a schism the best evidence that this is
the actual case is Alexandra Ocasio
Cortes so a lot of folks on the Left
have been suggesting that people on the
right are paying outsized attention to
Ocasio cortes it's one it's a point of
great irritation to me if you elevate
somebody to a leading position in your
party and then we point out that this
person doesn't know things about
politics that is not our fault that's
your fault
for elevating that person to a lead
position I don't remember the left
taking the same position about for
example Sarah Palin when they mocked the
living daylights out of Sarah Palin for
stuff she didn't even say I don't
remember them saying well you know kind
of mean of us to mock this Sarah Pett
they said you picked her for VP we got
to mock her okay Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
you elevated her we got to mock her that
said Ocasio Cortez is proving that the
left wing of the Democratic Party is
willing to work with the mainstream wing
of the Democratic Party they're willing
to move the party overall to the left
and they're willing to pledge fealty to
the current leadership in order to do
this I'll Cascio Cortes for example has
now backed Nancy Pelosi in this battle
she says that people who are criticizing
Nancy Pelosi don't understand the wonder
of Nancy Pelosi
I do think that we got sent to Congress
on a mandate to change how government
works to change what government even
looks like but if we are not on the same
page about changing the systems and the
values and how we're going to adapt as a
party for the future then what is the
point of just changing our party
leadership just for the sake of it hey
and she is this is this is smart
politicking by Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
so before the write thinks that the left
is gonna fragment I don't think the left
is gonna fragment in 2020 the same way
that they did in 2016 if Bernie Sanders
runs he is not gonna be running hard
against the establishment candidate
there is no establishment to point to
candidate they got rid of the
super-delegates that means there will be
a hard-fought primary campaign but in
the end the Democrats are gonna unify
around someone in a way they did not
unify around Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton circa 2016 so we shouldn't be
particularly sanguine about exactly
about the Democrats caving in and again
the Democrats instead are just moving to
co-opt their own base the mainstream
Democratic Party has embraced talk of
voter suppression and voter fraud their
mainstream characters are saying the
same thing as members of their base it's
dangerous stuff but it is an indicator
that the Democratic Party is in fact
unified so opposition creates unity it
does
hey the Republicans were more unified in
opposition to Barack Obama than they are
when it comes to governance the
Democrats are exactly the same way
they're more fragmented when they are in
power they are less fragmented when they
are in the opposition right now the
Democrats are in the opposition this
gives them the power of unification and
if Republicans don't recognize that then
they
making a crucial political error now
with all of that said and the the
Democrats as I say are moving radically
to the left I have a couple of stories
to prove that which I'll get to in just
one second so Story number one proving
that the Democrats are moving radically
to the left it's quite fascinating right
now there is a battle inside the the far
left hardcore base of the Democratic
Party as to whether anti-semitism is
okay
yeah the this is broken out into the
open with regard to the women's March so
according to James Barrett over at Daily
wire the leadership of the women's March
has come under fire from some of the
groups once most vocal supporters
including the woman who founded the
group and actresses Alyssa Milano and
Debra Messing the embattled leaders have
since responded to criticism with an
intersectional II loaded statement
blasting its critics earlier this year
feminist Hallie gold chef launched a
change.org petition calling on the
leadership of the women's March bob'll
and Tameka Mallory Linda Sarsour and
Carmen Perez to resign citing their
affiliation with and refusal to condemn
notorious racist bigot and anti-semite
Louis Farrakhan the petition reads many
feminists refused to join the women's
March because they did not feel
comfortable with the current leadership
now women's March participants also no
longer feel represented by this
organization due to the behavior of its
current leadership and so they say they
refuse to march behind those
particularly ders both mulatto and
messin disavowed the women's March due
to its current leadership on Monday the
women's March founder woman him Teresa
shook added her voice to the growing
chorus of feminists calling on all these
leaders to step down for allowing
bigotry racism anti LGBT sentiment and
anti-semitism to become part of the
platform she called for the current
co-chairs to step down and let others
lead who can restore faith in the
movement and its original intent the
leaders instead fired back and they said
that they will not step down they said
that we don't know everything we have
caused harm at times who have responded
with hurt but we are committed to
learning and we are building an
intersectional movement our daughters
and our daughters daughters can be proud
of now why do I think that the women's
March will survive all of this because I
think instead what you're going to see
is the mainstreaming of anti-semitism I
think what you're going to see is the
left growing more radical in every
conceivable way including the
mainstreaming of anti-semitism the
latest indicator of that mainstreaming
is not just their embrace of to Congress
women who have overtly called for a
boycott against the State of Israel but
the manes
of that sentiment among corporate
entities that reside on the political
left Airbnb the home rental company that
is often used by tourists to rent
apartments and locations around the
globe for example announced yesterday
that it would not allow Jewish
settlements to be listed in Judea and
Samaria in other words they say that if
you are a Jew and you live in Efrat in
Israel they will not allow you to rent
out your apartment on Airbnb this is a
sheer form of corporate anti-semitism
but it's ok with the left because
anti-semitism is okay with the left so
long as the anti-semitism is coming from
people who are more dispossessed than
the Jews this is how it works in
intersectional world not only did Airbnb
specifically target is railey
settlements they only targeted Jews okay
so they weren't saying that they won't
rent an apartment in a fraud they said
they won't rent any Jewish owned
apartment in a fraud so if you're an
Arab but if you're a Christian and
you're a Muslim then they will allow you
as long as you're not a Jew they will
rent your apartment in a fraud but if
you're a Jew then they will not allow
you to rent out your apartment in a
fraud on Airbnb Airbnb list of parts in
Turkish occupied Cyprus Moroccan
occupied Sahara Chinese occupied Tibet
russian-occupied Crimea then rent
apartments in some of the most
dictatorial places all around the world
but they will not allow a Jew to rent
out his apartment in East Jerusalem
where he is living legally okay this is
corporate anti-semitism and it's totally
okay with the far-left because again the
far left is unifying the Democratic
Party what we are seeing is a
radicalization of the Democratic Party
because it is easier to move with the
radicals than to cast out the radicals
the Democratic Party is is becoming more
and more dangerous because they are
indeed a cohesive force these battles do
not carry any real weight between people
who are against anti-semitism and for
anti-semitism in the Democratic Party
the radicals are going to win out and
they're gonna shift the mainstream over
to them whenever you hear folks on the
Left talk about how the right is radical
recognized that the right in this
country has not shifted its political
position since 2010 all movement on the
political spectrum all every bit of it
has come from the American left which is
moving further and further to the left
and is cohesive in that move
specifically now because they exist in
operation in opposition to President
Trump now sometimes this radicalization
has some pretty funny side effects this
is a pretty great story the Women's
Resource Center at Eastern Michigan has
put the kibosh
on its production of The Vagina
Monologues why because it was supposed
to cater to women and not all women have
vaginas is a real story Eastern Michigan
is now not allowing the Vagina
Monologues because it's about women and
there are some transgender men who are
women pretty spectacular stuff is that
gay it's funny but it's more sad than
funny because unfortunately this is the
direction in which the left has chosen
to move a sane left would be better for
the country than an insane left but I
don't think that that is in the offing
any time soon okay time for a couple of
things that I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like we've
been doing some William Goldman's stuff
this week because he passed away last
week he wrote probably the best memoir
on Hollywood ever written called
adventures in the screen trade a
personal view of Hollywood and
screenwriting and the book is just
fantastic it talks about all of his sort
of stories from Hollywood how he got in
the business his dealings with various
studio entities and studio heads and
actors and writers it's really fantastic
it's a great quick read this is one of
his two great books about Hollywood I'll
probably recommend the other one
tomorrow it's really worthwhile so if
you're if you're looking for a fun read
during the Thanksgiving weekend go check
out adventures in the screen trade by
William Goldman okay other things that I
like so Dan Crenshaw is a congressperson
from Texas and Dan Crenshaw is just
spectacular he was on one of the sunday
shows and it was on Face the Nation on
CBS and one of the Democrats suggested
that President Trump was undermining all
of the key American institutions and Dan
Crenshaw who is a Navy SEAL who lost his
eye fighting in Afghanistan Dan Crenshaw
has some of the best response I've ever
seen on national television it's just
spectacular how was that impressed
though because it's literally in a title
I've literally been attacked you know I
choose our words carefully language is
and it took us so why can't he speak
white why is he not allowed to use his
own language and freedom of speech
because and you talked about this
actually it's important that we lead for
an example that we lead from the top and
the way that our president is I agree
with you there I agree with you their
style is one thing if you want a
criticized style I'm with you right but
to say it's an attack on the freedom of
the press that is a very bold statement
by calling the press the
enemy of the people language literally
okay so the style I agree I don't like
that one okay and here's exactly right
but I love that she says it's literally
an attack on the price like um no no
like see this right here
this eyepatch that was literally an
attack hey it is amazing how people have
have radically changed the nature of the
language in order to fit their attacks
on president Trump okay one more thing
that I like so Kate Fagan is leaving
ESPN you may have seen her on First Take
and around the horn she served as a
fill-in host on outside the lines why is
she leaving she's leaving because she
says to continue at ESPN I would have to
be immersed in the day to day in sports
and I found myself more and more
interested in other aspects of sports
like how it connects to our culture that
was not going to be the big business of
ESPN I desperately hope so I desperately
hope that ESPN returns to covering
sports last night's Monday Night
Football game by the way between the
Rams and the Chiefs was utterly
unbelievable how about covering sports
because that's what people like watching
they don't want to see Kate Fagan
comment about LGBT bicycle races no one
cares about that crap that's not why I
turn on ESPN but ESPN has lost ratings
for one reason because you cannot turn
on ESPN without getting social justice
warrior discussions about just how
heroic Caitlyn Jenner is or how heroic
Fallon Fox is a man fighting women in
UFC
I'm so glad P n is else ting all of the
political actors on ESPN good that would
be great because they obviously won't
have anyone who's remotely right-wing on
the network they fired everybody else
now this is this this is this woman Kate
Fagan she says I thought I think I
thought at one point that I wanted to do
a show that made women's sports really
cool I thought there could be a show on
some of the tangential topics LGBT
issues and mental health five years ago
I thought I could host a show that
introduces new female characters to
women's sports world this again this
isn't the ESPN's fault but I'm not that
naive now you know why that show
wouldn't fly cuz no one cares about
women's soccer outside of the Women's
World Cup every four years when we all
pretend to care about women's soccer we
care about women's tennis cuz women's
tennis is really good no one cares about
women's basketball and no one cares
about LGBT issues in the locker room in
female lacrosse
it turns out what we actually want is to
watch games where people hit each other
and hold balls and then throw them to
each other like that's that's
we want that's all we've been asking for
I used to get up at 6:00 in the morning
so I could watch the highlights on
SportsCenter I have not watched
SportsCenter for seven years because of
their political bent I am not the only
one who feels this way okay so if the
SPN decides to move back toward sports
that would definitely be an upgrade over
the garbage that they've been
programming for the last several years
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate so here in California obviously
been having some massive horrendous
wildfires probably hundreds dead in the
Northern California wildfires Shelby
grad is the assistant managing editor of
the LA Times and Shelby grad tweeted out
that Jerry Brown the governor here who
is 1 million years old and actually
remembers the Pleistocene era he
actually Shelby tweets out Jerry Brown
told the truth about California fires
that no one wants to hear what is that
truth that truth is there are too many
people I love that for the left when you
suck at being a governor you just got to
claim there are too many people it's
amazing so if you're on the right and
people on the left say income inequality
you say right income inequality has
existed in every society every time the
only thing we should be worried about is
whether the impoverished in the United
States are able to grow economically
then they say ah you're ignoring you're
ignoring hope you're ignoring change
like well mode inequality is existed for
all of time that's it that's a reality
but if you're on the left and you say
yeah a bunch of people gonna die in
wildfires cuz there are too many humans
then they're like good answer good
answer
here's what Jerry Brown says he says you
know we've had fires for the loan before
the Europeans showed up here and our
indigenous people had a different way of
living with nature for 10,000 years
there were number more than 300,000
people living in California now we have
40 million and we have a totally
different situation here members because
10,000 years ago Jerry Brown was there
he actually observed how many people
were there says so it's not one thing
it's people it's how people live it's
where they live it's the change in
climate and the truth is we're gonna
have more difficulties except as it
turns out Jerry Brown fully understands
why the wildfires have gotten so bad in
the state of California you know why the
wildfires have gotten so bad in the
state of California because of state
policy that stinks okay back in August
he basically acknowledged as much the
Santa Cruz Sentinel reported back in
August before the wildfires that Brown
was proposing one of the most
significant changes to the state's
logging rules in your
half a century according to Emily
Zanotti over daily wire Governor Jerry
Brown is proposing broad new changes to
California's logging rules that would
allow landowners to cut larger trees and
build temporary roads without obtaining
a permit as a way to thin more forests
across the state under Brown's proposal
private landowners would be able to cut
trees up to 36 inches in diameter so
long as their purpose was to thin
forests or reduce fire risk so he
understood like a couple of months ago
that one of the reasons these big fires
were happening is because of crappy fire
policy it's not just people on the right
saying this by the way you know Trump
tweeted out this and people were like ah
how could he how could he tweet this out
now shouldn't a tweeted that he was
gonna throw a fire eh that was
ridiculous but he wasn't wrong than it
is fire management policies in the state
of California that have exacerbated the
risk of bad fires how do I know this
because Mother Jones the Communist
magazine they they wrote a piece back in
December called a century of fire
suppression is why California is in
flames this piece points out that
because they have not actually
participated in fire suppression meaning
like controlled fires controlled burns
they get rid of a lot of the undergrowth
when fires do happen
there are basically giant conflagrations
according to according to experts like
Sasha Berman who's a fire ecologist the
biggest problem here is 100 years of
fire suppression that has led to a huge
accumulation of fuel loads just dead and
downed trees from debris from trees and
plant materials in our forests and our
Woodlands as a result of that our
forests and woodlands are not healthy
and we're getting more catastrophic fire
behavior than we would otherwise okay so
even Jerry Brown recognizes this but I
love that the media are basically
covering for him and saying you know
what it's not that Jerry Brown is bad at
his job it's that there are too many
people living he said the same thing
about the I love this he did say the
same thing with regard to the drought in
the state of California so it turns out
we've had several tens of millions of
people in California for as long as I
have been alive and we've also had
drought problems in California for as
long as I've been alive we could have
built all new infrastructure we could
have worked on desalination plans we
could have worked on ensuring that we
weren't pumping millions of gallons of
fresh water out into the San Francisco
Bay in order protect the delta smelt
there's lots of stuff we could have done
instead Jerry Brown just said there are
too many people living in the state of
California I love that that's a good
excuse there are too many people you
notice how the left always comes
to that abortion makes the economy
better because there are too many people
you know what we really a global warming
is bad because there are too many people
ok so which which million people would
you kill who you want to do who you want
to off here if Jerry I promise you Jerry
Brown is not interested in in killing
off members of his own California
constituency I would imagine it's
incredible what you can get away with if
you happen to be on the political left
ok well we will be back here tomorrow
with all the latest as we approach
Thanksgiving I know I'm in a good mood
shouldn't you be in a good mood - come
on there's a lot to be thankful for
we'll be back here tomorrow to discuss
all of it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018